who do you think it's scarier Trump or
kim jonghwan Donald Trump Donald Trump
John Kim why tripped over all your
financials in Japan why oh I'm good so I
don't know how I'm gonna I think well
you're not getting me on sometimes I buy
them didn't they jump on the menu it got
there come on come on
tensions between the u.s. and North
Korea are majorly escalating with both
President Trump and Kim jong-un
exchanging heated rhetoric and scary
threat they will be met with fire and
fury like the world has never seen
caught in the middle of the war of words
the missile tests and the military
exercises are the 76 million people
living here on the Korean Peninsula
they're the ones who bear the brunt of
any attack so we're in South Korea where
it looks like business as usual but how
scared are people here
[Music]
stop talking to Warren is 14 there okay
switch other more under caution Peter in
the Toyota for comment even consider him
more yogi number two shall immediately
terminate epigenomic for this in case of
two into wild and hypothesis what do you
think about the heated words that
they've been exchanging and the
possibility of war breaking out well as
a native Korean I leave 20 years under
the constant fear of breaking war
breaking out so I am kind of became you
thought about that you're used to it and
is what do you think about North Korea
and the people there sorry
humility mahogany Car Talk Iran's a
fundamental change to kill the artists I
know do you think that North and South
Korea will ever be reunified I don't
think like very what happened separated
too long and I think it's hard to
overcome that difference right now they
objected Tony
da da da nya at all captain me too sir
are you worried about the tensions right
now between North Korea and the United
States okay boo-boo name-o
okay all about internet song in a boat
together so many times a North Korea
that wheat Korea Korea before but never
happened that nothing happened before so
other thing is it's nothing it happen so
you're not scared right now
I'm not scared that's where I live in
San Francisco in the United States right
now a lot of people are freaking out and
they're afraid that a nuclear war might
break out you're not worried just little
bit worried about it just a little bit
hi everyone it's Deena make sure you
check out all of the videos in this
series from South Korea and let me know
what you think in the comments be sure
to like and share this video and
subscribe to aj+